i got a call from a brand new dad
this morning take a listen to this
voicemail
left to me uh at 219 to
david p hey david uh
long time listener first time caller
here from a live heart to seattle watch
yes
listen uh my daughter my first daughter
was born um
about 20 minutes ago and one of my first
thoughts is
wow oh my gosh i just brought a child
into this world during this election
and during everything that's going on
i'd just love for you to give a shout
out on your show to my daughter nikoia
and uh just reassure me that i'm gonna
be able to raise my daughter in this
world
all right thank you you do a great job
and i really appreciate your work well
listen
congratulations welcome to the world to
nicoya
um i think we have to be realistic here
you we
we don't have contro much like i said to
the caller yesterday the philosophy of
stoicism comes to mind
clearly what matters is whether this new
dad
does everything he can
to improve the world for his daughter
ultimately it is not up to him uh a
planet of seven
eight billion people is not one that can
be controlled
by just one person but the fact that
you're thinking
in these terms tells me uh that you're
going to do a great job and uh we all
have to work together
in order to uh create the best possible
situation not just for
our kids but their kids and their kids
and their kids and we do have a
monumental
uh event that could alter the course of
history coming up just a few weeks from
now
on the bonus show today a saudi court
has sentenced
suspects in the jamal khashoggi murder
we will talk about a uh coronavirus
guideline
avoiding bar which secretly had 300
people inside of it
and we will also talk about the
continuation of julian assange's
extradition hearing
this story is still going on and it's
unlikely to go away anytime soon
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show remember
this program is mostly funded by members
i am asking you for your support if you
like what we do
or even if you hate it but think it's
important grab yourself a membership at
joinpackman.com
and you'll be able to join us on the
bonus show as well